mais il me faut savoir que tous les
avions de ligne sont régulièrement
régulièrement passer au peigne fin si
j'ose dire partout les techniciens c'est
en tout cas ce que vous explique
maintenant frédéric stoxx dans ses
ateliers de la proche banlieue de
toulouse et techniciens d'air france
connaissent sur le bout des doigts
toutes les pièces qui constituent un
avion de ligne
ici la spécialité du centre c'est la
révision et l'entretien d'un type précis
d'appareils ceux qui ont des fuselage
étroit comme les boeing 727 ou 737
les gros porteurs tels que le 747 sont
eux pris en charge par d'autres ateliers
de la compagnie air france à orly et à
roissy
mais six à sept ans les appareils
passant révision générale complète
complète ce qui n'empêche pas qu'entre
temps il y a quand même des révisions
partielles
c'est cela à mi parcours nous avons une
visite intermédiaires qui a immobilisé
l'avion beaucoup moins de temps
nécessite beaucoup moins d'heures de
travail et c'est à peu près tous les
trois ans en plus de ces révisions
importantes des appareils de la
compagnie air france sont également
l'objet de visites de routine après
chaque vol ces contrôles sont effectués
sur place là où se trouve l'avion à son
retour au cas où une anomalie aurait été
signalé par l'équipage ou par le
mécanicien au sol la réparation peut
avoir lieu ici à toulouse montaudran
les techniciens du centre ont ainsi été
chargé en février dernier de remettre en
état ce wing 737 détourné en 1984 par
des pirates de l'air sur l'aéroport de
téhéran un travail qui représente plus
de dix mille heures d'efforts
il